The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DENNIS FREEMAN:
Hello and welcome.
Today, we're starting the
second half of the class.
In the second half
of the class, we'll
focus on methods that
will generally be
described as Fourier methods.
And those methods revolve
around thinking about signals
as being sums of sine waves.
So we've previously
thought about how
you can think about a
system by thinking about how
it responds to sine waves.
So this is closely related.
Now, instead of
thinking about a system
by how it processes
these sine waves.
Rather, we'll
think about signals
as being composed of sine waves.
So that's sort of the idea.
And today, we'll do
the very simplest kind
of representation, which
is a Fourier series.
The importance of that's going
to be our first encounter
with how you can think
about complicated signals
as sums of sines and cosines.
But also, we'll get
a new representation
for a system that
will be generally
useful called a filter.
So that's the two
agenda items for today.
Roughly, the first half
is on the Fourier series
representations for a signal.
The second half is on
thinking about systems
as filters, which is a direct
consequence of the first.
So the first idea is
just, why should we
even think that you
can think about signals
in terms of sine waves?
Well, there's very
simple examples of that.
Some signals are just very
naturally described that way.
One class of those are the ones
whose entire frequency content
are harmonics.
Just a bit of jargon, we'll
think about harmonics of omega
0, harmonics of some frequency.
Say, 1 kilohertz.
Then we'll have
the first harmonic.
That's another name
for the fundamental.
That's 1 kilohertz, for example.
Second harmonic would
be some component
at twice the frequency.
Third harmonic, three
times the frequency.
0-th harmonic for
the completely--
so for no good
reason at all, we'll
call them 0-th
harmonic the DC term,
meaning Direct Current,
which is neither direct
nor has anything
to do with current.
But we will use that jargon
because everybody else does.
So that's just jargon.
What I want to think about
though at a deeper level is,
what kinds of signals
should we expect
have a good
representation in terms
of sums of sines and cosines?
And one very easy kind of
signal that you can think about
is signals that we associate
with musical instruments.
So think about the sounds that
these instruments generate.
And I'll play some audio.
And while I'm playing
it, what you're
supposed to be doing
is thinking about,
what's the cues that this
sounds like a sum of harmonics?
[PLAYING NOTES]
So using the things that we'll
go over today in lecture,
I can write a Python
program, which
I did, to analyze
each of those sounds
to expose its
harmonic structure.
And here's the results.
So for k equals 0, DC1,
the fundamental, 2,
the second harmonic, third
harmonic, fourth harmonic.
The lengths of the bars
represent the magnitudes,
how much energy--
well, roughly energy.
How much signal is
present at those harmonic
frequencies as a function of
harmonic number k for each
of the different instruments?
And just like the time wave
forms have a signature,
there was a
characteristic shape.
In fact, if I go on, here
is the characteristic shape.
That's an actual wave form
taken from the audio clip
that I played.
That's a clip from the piano.
This is a clip of the same
time duration from the violin.
A clip of the same time
duration from the bassoon.
And here are the
harmonic structures
for those different sounds.
And you can see the harmonic
structures look very different.
So not much DC.
A fair amount of
fundamental, a lot of second.
A lot of fundamental,
not too much second.
Not much fundamental.
That's kind of interesting.
The bassoon is
special in this class
because there's not
much fundamental,
but there's a lot of second.
So now, think about
comparing these two
and listen to them again.
[PLAYING NOTES]
So what I want you to
try to think about--
and it's kind of hard.
Think about how it is that the
harmonic structure is playing
a role in determining
the timbre of the sound
that you're hearing.
OK.
So that's kind of
the motivation.
Another motivation is that
thinking about signals
in terms of their
harmonic structure
can provide important
insights into the signals.
And so for example in music,
the harmonic structure
is what determines
consonance and dissonance.
Dissonance.
So I'm going to play
two different notes that
are related by an octave
shift, by a fifth shift,
and adjacent notes in
the semitone scale.
And below it, I've illustrated
the harmonic structure
for the D and for D prime.
OK.
So an octave above means
that the first harmonic,
the fundamental of
this guy, corresponds
to the second
harmonic of this guy.
The second to the
fourth, et cetera.
There's some relationship for
the fifths illustrated here.
And there's a different
relationship here.
So what I want you to do
is to hear the difference
between those six sounds.
And again, think about not
only the time waveform,
but also how their
harmonics relate.
[PLAYING NOTES]
So dissonance has something
to do-- well, consonance
has something to
do with the overlap
of the harmonic
structure and dissonance
has something to do
with the lack of overlap
of the harmonic content.
So the point just being that
we can get some mileage out
of thinking about
signals according
to their harmonic decomposition.
So that's kind of
the introduction.
How should we think about that?
What kinds of signals
ought to be representable
by their harmonic structure?
OK.
Well if you just draw a
picture in a time domain
and think about a
fundamental, what would it
look like in the time domain?
What would the signal look like?
What would the second
harmonic look like?
Well, that's a signal whose
frequency is twice as big.
If the frequency is twice as
big, the period is half as big.
So there's now two periods of
the blue guy in the same time
interval as one
period of the red guy.
So the relationship of
frequencies in the harmonics
has a relationship in time.
It's inversely proportional.
OK.
So if you think about
fundamental, second, third,
fourth, fifth.
Fundamental, second,
third, fourth, fifth.
There's a relationship
in time of the periods.
And one thing that
should be clear
is that these harmonics are
all periodic in the period
of the fundamental.
So one thing that
you can think about,
by thinking about the time
representation of what
harmonic signals ought to
look like, periodic signals
are sort of our only candidates.
All of the harmonics
of a fundamental
will have the same--
are periodic in capital T,
the period of the fundamental.
So it's going to
be hard to generate
a signal by a sum
of harmonics that
doesn't have that periodicity.
So we should be expecting a
relationship between signals
that can be represented
by a sum of harmonics
and periodic signals.
So we would not expect
an aperiodic signal
to be represented this way.
The counter question
is, should we
be expecting that all periodic
signals can be represented
this way, or some
periodic signals,
or some very special class?
Is it a big class
or a small class?
How do we think about that?
And historically, that's
been a hard question.
And by the end of the hour, I
hope that you all understand
why it was a hard question.
People, like Fourier,
you might imagine,
advocated the
notion that you can
make a meaningful harmonic
representation for a very
wide class of signals.
Fourier claimed,
basically, everything.
Anything that was periodic
could be represented
in terms of a sum of harmonics.
Other people thought
that was preposterous.
In a widely reported
public rebuke of Fourier,
Lagrange said,
this is ridiculous,
because every harmonic is a
continuous function of time.
And you can easily
manufacture a periodic signal
that's a discontinuous
function of time.
So for example, a square wave.
How on earth are you--
Lagrange, how on earth
would you represent
a discontinuous function by a
sum of continuous functions?
That makes no sense.
So what we will want to do
in the course of the hour
is think about, does that
or doesn't that make sense?
And it will turn out the
answer is kind of complicated.
And so we can sort
of forgive both sides
for having sort of
argued with each other
because the answer is
not completely obvious.
For the time being, I'm
going to just assume
that the answer is yes,
that it makes sense
to try to make a harmonic
representation of a signal that
might even be discontinuous.
I'm going to assume
periodic, let's try.
And the question will be,
does that make any sense?
So there's a little bit of math.
There's a mathematical
foundation
that makes understanding these
Fourier series very easy.
The idea has two parts.
First off, if you have a
sinusoidally-varying signal
here at frequency k omega
0, the k-th harmonic.
If you were to multiply
the k-th harmonic
times the l-th harmonic, a
signal of frequency k omega 0
times a signal of
frequency l omega 0,
you get a new harmonic,
the k plus l-th one.
That's a simple property
of the way the product
of two exponents--
you add the exponents
when you take the product
of two exponentials.
OK.
So that makes it very easy to
think about harmonic structure
because there's a simple
relationship for generating
one harmonic signal in
time from another harmonic
signal in time.
The second thing
that makes harmonics
easy to think about
mathematically
is that if you integrate
over a period--
we'll do this so often that
we'll abbreviate it this way.
Because if you have a
signal that's periodic,
it really doesn't
matter which period you
choose to do the integral over.
If you had a signal that was
periodic in, say, capital T,
and integrated it between 0
and T. And if it's periodic,
you should be able
to shift that window
anywhere you like and you
should get the same thing.
So we'll not worry about whether
it goes from 0 to capital T
or from 1 to capital T plus 1.
We won't worry about that.
We'll just say integrate
over the period T.
If you integrate over the
period T any harmonic signal,
then there's only
two possible answers.
So if you integrate
e to the jk omega
0 T over one period
of omega 0, there
will be k periods in there.
So if k is a number
other than 0,
you'll have complete
periods of a sine wave.
So the answer of the
integral, the average value
over that period, is 0.
The only time you'll ever
get something that's non-zero
is if k were 0.
If k were 0, if it were
DC, then e to the 0 is 1.
The integral of 1 over a period,
regardless of what period
you pick up, the integral
of 1 over a period
is capital T. So two things.
It's easy to figure
out the product
of two harmonic signals.
It's just the
different harmonic.
And integrals over
a period are easy.
With that basis, then
it's easy to say how--
let's imagine that some
arbitrary periodic signal,
which we can always write this
way, x of t, if it's periodic,
could also be written x of
t plus capital T if x of t
is periodic in capital T. Let's
assume that that can be written
as a sum of harmonics.
So a sum-- k equals
minus infinity
to infinity of some amount
of e to the j omega 0 kt.
Why do I have the
minus k's in there?
OK.
I've asked this question
about six times.
Why do I have the
minus k's in there?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: Precisely.
We like Euler's equation.
We like complex numbers.
We don't like cosine and sines.
And we can convert
sines and cosines
into complex exponentials
using Euler's formula
and everything's very easy.
So we use minus k
for the same reason
that we used minus omega in
previous representations.
So imagine that we
can write x of t,
some generic periodic signal,
as a sum of harmonics.
Then, let's use those principles
that we talked about before.
If that can be
represented as a sum,
I can sift out the
one of interest
by multiplying x of t times
e to the minus jl omega 0.
We'll see in a minute
what I mean by "sift out"
and why I'm using
minus instead of plus.
If you were to run this
integral over a period--
and imagine for the moment that
all the sums are well-behaved,
so nothing explodes.
And so all the convergence
issues are trivial.
If the convergence
issues were trivial,
then I could swap the
sum and the integral.
If I did that, then I would
end up with a sum of a bunch
of different k's.
But for each one,
I'd be taking some--
the k-th harmonic times
the minus l-th harmonic.
And that's going to give me 0
when I integrate over a period,
except when k equals l.
If k equals l, then I'm
going to get capital T.
So the net effect of doing
this is to generate T a l.
It sifts out one of
those coefficients.
Well, that's nice.
That means that if I assume I
can write the signal this way,
then I can sift out
the k-th coefficient
by integrating against
minus the k-th and divide
by T because of
the normalization.
Because if you integrate 1 over
a period, you get capital T.
And that tells me then
that if this were true,
this is how you'd
find the coefficient.
So that leads to what we call
a set of analysis and synthesis
equations.
So that if x can be represented
this way, if we can synthesize
a periodic signal x
by adding together
a bunch of harmonic components
with a suitable weighting
factor.
The weighting factor
a sub k certainly
has a different magnitude,
just like those musical tones
that I played at the
beginning, those musical notes.
All of the different k's
had different amplitudes.
They also have different phases.
The a sub k can be
a complex number.
We like complex numbers.
Complex numbers are easy.
So if we can represent
x by a sum of harmonics,
complex valued.
So weighted by a
complex number, then we
can sift out what those
weight factors were by running
the analysis equation.
We can analyze the
signal to figure out
how much of the k-th
component is there.
So the strategy then is
assume that all works.
That is to say, let's
talk an ugly signal
of the type that
caused controversy back
in the mid-1800s.
Let's take a controversial
signal like a square wave,
assume it all works,
and figure out what
the ak's would have had to be.
And then we'll figure out
whether that made any sense.
So if this thing were to
be represented by a Fourier
series, by a sum of harmonic
components, how many of these
statements would be true about
those harmonic amplitudes?
So as you start to write,
look toward your neighbor
and say hi.
Then, write and
figure out the answer.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
OK.
So how many of those
statements are true?
Raise your hand with a number
of fingers between 0 and 5
would seem good limits.
How many statements are true?
OK, we've got about 40% correct.
So that's a little under half.
What do I do first?
If I want to figure
this out, what would
I do to try to figure out--
so statement 1, a sub
k is 0 if k is even.
Should that be true or false?
How do I think about that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The square
wave [INAUDIBLE]..
DENNIS FREEMAN: The
square wave's odd.
OK.
That sounds good.
So how does that help me?
AUDIENCE: If there was an even
term in the Fourier series,
then that would mess up
the oddness [INAUDIBLE]..
DENNIS FREEMAN: So I might
want to have only odd terms.
How many terms in the Fourier
decomposition are odd and even?
What is the Fourier
decomposition?
So let's start by just writing
some definition, right?
So I want to say
that x of t is--
let's see.
I have a period of 1.
That's the same as x
of t plus 1, right?
And I want to write this as
some sort of a Fourier thing.
So what do I write next?
I want to say that this
signal can be represented
by some sum of something.
And I'm going to have
to put some weights in.
And I'm going to want something
like e to the minus j 2 pi
kt by T, something like that.
And I'm going to need
a whole bunch of these.
Where does even and odd show up?
So if I were to rewrite
this as sines and cosines.
So I could rewrite this in terms
of some sines and some cosines.
Then, the decomposition
into even and odd is easier.
That's correct.
So let's get back to this one.
How do I think about
this one, though?
So I want k to be even.
What does k even correspond to?
OK.
Let's assume I don't
know what k even.
How do I do this if I
don't know anything?
How do I just grunt through it?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Just do the integral.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Just do
the integral, exactly.
So what I'd like to do is
say that a sub k is 1--
so assuming everything works.
Assuming everything
works, then a sub k
should be the integral over t
weighted by 1 over t, x of t
e to the minus j 2 pi kt over T.
I should have put a plus there.
I want the minus sign
in one of the formulas
and not in the other one.
OK.
And if you just think about that
integral, it's not very hard.
So I want this kind of thing.
Capital T is 1.
So I get two pieces,
the piece that
corresponds to the minus
a 1/2 and plus 1/2.
And when I integrate them, I get
something that's a little bit--
well, no.
It's pretty
straightforward, right?
So you integrate this
thing, the 1 over minus--
and so the minus j 2 pi
k flips into the bottom.
The 1/2 turns it into j 4
pi k-- blah, blah, blah.
You get four pieces.
These two pieces
correspond to 1.
They sum to 2.
So you get that.
The point is that it's a
pretty simple transformation
to think about the
square wave turning
into a sequence of amplitudes.
So if you choose--
let's see.
So if you choose k
to be even, then I've
got an integer multiple of 2 pi.
If k were even,
then I would have
an integer multiple of 2 pi.
e to the integer multiple
of 2 pi flips around to 1.
As does the minus 1.
That kills this stuff.
OK.
So that's where the k
even and k odd comes from.
So the point is that
there's a simple way
to just crank through it and
we get a simple representation.
So we get that ak is 1 over
j pi k, k odd, 0 otherwise.
OK.
And then we can just sort of
run down through the list.
We'll see in a minute why this
particular list of properties
is interesting.
So a sub k is 0 if k is even?
Yep.
ak is real?
Nope, there's a j in it.
ak magnitude decreases
with k square?
Nope.
Decreases with k.
There's an infinite
number of non-zero terms?
Yup.
k goes to infinity.
All of the above?
Obviously not.
The point is it's simple
to do and you end up
representing the time waveform
by just a sequence of numbers.
How big is the fundamental?
How big is the second harmonic?
How big is the third
harmonic, et cetera.
There's some more math that
makes things even easier.
There are ways of thinking
about operations in time
as equivalent
operations in harmonics.
That makes the idea
even more powerful
because what we
are developing is
an alternative
representation for signals.
The same as we had multiple
representations for systems--
differential equations, block
diagrams, h of t, h of s,
h of r, Bode plots, all those
different representations
of systems, this represents
an alternative representation
of a signal.
We think about it being
represented in time
or we think about it being
represented in harmonics.
Or eventually, we'll
call that frequency.
So we'll think about
signals being represented
in time or frequency.
And you can think
about operations
in time having a corresponding
operation in frequency.
So illustrated here, if a signal
is differentiated in time,
the Fourier coefficients are
multiplied by j 2 pi over T k.
OK, well that's easy.
If we assume for
the moment that we
can represent x as
this kind of a sum,
differentiation is linear.
The derivative of a sum is
the sum of the derivatives.
The derivative of
sine wave is easy.
And we end up with the idea that
if you knew the a sub k's, then
you can easily formulate
the series representation
for the harmonic
structure by just
multiplying each of the ak's
by the power of the exponent.
OK.
So that gives us a way of
thinking about signals in time
as being represented
in frequency.
So here's an
illustration of that.
Imagine that we have a triangle
wave rather than a square wave.
Answer the same questions.
And be aware that it's a trick.
By "trick," I mean you could
use the obvious approach, which
is the one we just did.
Or you could use some
insight from the last slide
and do it in one step.
So how many of these
statements are true?
Everybody, raise your hand.
Raise the number of
fingers equal to the number
of correct statements.
We've got complete
switch of who's right.
And still, 40% correct.
That's phenomenal.
So we could just go
through the list.
What's the trick?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: So close.
So integral, exactly.
Right.
This signal is the integral
of the previous signal.
So that means that
we ought to be able--
there's some kind of
a simple relationship
between this series
and the series
that represents that one.
What should I do to this one
to make it look like that one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: Divide
by j 2 pi k, precisely.
So I can think about the bk's
being the ak's, but then I
have to worry about
the representation
for differentiation.
Or here, integration in
the frequency domain.
In the frequency
domain, integration
corresponds to
dividing by j 2 pi k.
So now, if I think about the
list of questions, is b0 for k
even?
Yeah, it was before.
It is now.
Because all we're doing
is changing the weights.
And if the weight
started out 0 and we're
multiplying by
something, we can't
get it to be different from 0.
Is it real-valued?
Well, now it is because
I had a j times j.
So now they are real-valued.
Does it decrease with k squared?
Now it does because
I got one of the k's
from the differentiation
operator and the other k
from over here.
Infinite number.
Of course, the old one did, too.
All of the above?
Yes.
OK.
So that was just supposed to
be a simple exercise in how
to run the formulas, how to
do the stuff from a purely
mechanical point of view.
Now I want to think about
the bigger question.
Does any of this make any sense?
And the answers were concocted
to help me make sense of that.
The questions, the
check yourselves,
were concocted so that if we
think about the answer that
came out, we will
have some insight
into why we think it works
and why it was controversial
150 years ago.
So let's do the
simple case first.
Even Lagrange wouldn't have
any trouble with this-- well,
maybe he would have
had a little trouble.
I guess he would have
So Lagrange had the
problem with Fourier
that Fourier was making
these outrageous claims
that any periodic function
should have a Fourier
decomposition.
And if you have a
discontinuous function,
and if all the basis
functions are continuous,
how could that make any sense?
This doesn't have
any discontinuities,
but it does have
slope discontinuities.
That's sort of the same thing.
If you have a
slope discontinuity
and you're trying to make--
you're trying to represent the
signal by a sum of signals,
none of whom have slope
discontinuities, that's kind
of the same kind of problem.
One way we can think
about it is to think
about how the approximation
gets better, or fails
to get better, as we add terms.
So this is the base function.
This is the signal that we would
like to represent harmonically.
If we just think about
the first non-zero term,
the first non-zero term
is the fundamental.
It actually is not bad.
If we were willing to accept
errors about this big,
it would be OK.
But somehow, it doesn't
capture much triangliness.
It sort of doesn't
look much [INAUDIBLE]..
So the one term sort of
catches a lot of the deviation,
but it doesn't capture
the triangle aspect.
If you add another term--
the next non-zero
term is the third one.
So if you write the sum of the
first term, the k equals 1 term
and the k equals 3 term,
you get this waveform.
Notice that the effect
of that was to creep it
toward the underlying signal.
If you add another term--
5, 7, 9-- it's getting
closer, closer, closer.
19 because I got bored
making the figures,
so I skipped a bunch.
29, because I skipped a bunch.
39.
You can see that
what's happening
is as we add more and
more of those terms,
by the time we got up to
number 39, it's pretty good.
So that probably from your seat,
it's not altogether apparent
that they're different.
They're still different.
But you can see that
there is a sense
in which the approximation
is converging
toward the underlying signal.
That's good.
So that's a sense
in which there is
a convergence between the signal
and its Fourier representation.
A different kind of
thing happens here.
Now, let's do the square wave.
If we put in the first term
of the Fourier representation,
which is the fundamental, we
get a sine wave approximation
which is a little worse
perhaps for a square wave
than it was for a triangle wave.
Put in the 3rd, 5th,
7th, 9th, 19th--
so I threw in 5 again--
29, 39.
It's not doing as well.
What's not doing as well?
So we go one-term partial sum--
2, 3, 4, 5, 20.
10, 15, 20.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's
not able to handle
the really quick transitions.
DENNIS FREEMAN: It's
not able to handle
the really quick transition.
It's kind of like
Lagrange said, right?
How are you going to make a
discontinuous function out
of a sum of continuous ones?
It's hard.
In fact, this is
called Gibbs phenomena,
after the guy who
sort of formulated
the mathematics of this.
Even in the limit, no
matter how many terms
you put into the sum, the worst
case deviation is about 9%.
You can't get rid of it.
So in some sense,
Lagrange is right.
You can't put enough
terms in there
so that it converges everywhere.
So the problem then becomes
that we can't really
think about convergence in
the familiar ways we like
to think about convergence.
Convergence at a point is not
a good way to think about it.
Because there's always a
point that deviates a lot.
And in fact, in
signal processing
we have lots of other ways
we think about convergence.
So in addition to being
9% overshoot, the Gibbs
phenomenon, what else
do you see as the trend
as you increase the number
of terms in the partial sum?
In addition to
converging and staying
sort of the same
height, what else
happened as I added
terms to the partial sum?
It got skinnier.
The deviations got crammed
toward the transition point.
And if I keep
adding them, they'll
get crammed more
and more in there.
And it's not like an impulse.
The height didn't get bigger.
The width got smaller.
Had the height got bigger,
we'd have been in trouble.
Because then we
would have said it
deviates from the
square wave by having
an impulse at the transition.
It doesn't have an impulse.
The height's staying the same.
The width is smashing towards 0.
The energy in that signal is
getting smaller and smaller.
So a different way to
think about convergence
is, how big is the energy
difference between the two
signals?
In that sense, this converges
and Fourier's right.
As you add terms, the energy
difference between the two
signals goes to 0.
That's the modern way of
thinking about the controversy.
There is an issue.
If we choose to think
about convergence
in terms of energy
difference, then we
can resolve the problem.
That's what we'll do.
That's the reason in lots of
the things that we talk about,
we haven't been too worried
about single points being off
of curves.
That's come up in
some of the homeworks
that we don't really
care too much that--
say you have a function that is
1 everywhere except one point.
There's no energy difference
between the signal that differs
by 1 point and the original.
It has a finite height,
but there's 0 width.
So there's no energy difference.
So that's the reason we haven't
been so worried about that
because we use this kind of
a definition of equality.
They're equal if there's no
energy difference between them.
And using that kind of a way
of thinking about things,
we get to write
Fourier decompositions,
harmonic decompositions,
for a wide range of signals.
Not all of them, right?
Fourier exaggerated.
But for a wide range of signals.
In fact, the definition
we will typically use,
is signals with finite energy
we'll be able to do this.
So now what I want to do is
the last part of this lecture,
I want to introduce how
thinking about a signal in terms
of its harmonic
structure lets us think
about systems differently.
So here, the idea
is we previously
thought about systems
as frequency responses.
In a frequency response, we
use the eigenfunction property.
You put in an eigenfunction, one
of these complex exponentials.
You get out the same
complex exponential
if the system is
linear time invariant.
And the eigenvalue is the
value of the system function
evaluated at the
frequency of interest.
We've done that before.
The neat thing that happens if
you think about Fourier series
is that you can
break down the input
into a sum of discrete parts.
The first harmonic, the 0-th
harmonic, the second harmonic,
the third harmonic.
And now, each one of those
parts was an eigenfunction.
And each one of those parts
gets preferentially amplified
and/or time-delayed according
to the frequency response
idea for the system.
That lets us think about
the effect of a system
is to filter the input.
The idea in a filter is
that systems do not--
LTI systems, Linear
Time Invariant systems--
the same kind of systems
that we've been thinking
about all along so far.
Linear time invariant systems
cannot create new frequencies.
If you put some
frequency in, that's
the frequency that comes out.
We've already seen that when we
talk about frequency response.
They can only scale the
magnitude and shift the phase.
They can't make new
frequencies all they can do
is change the amplitude
and the phase.
And that's a very interesting
way to think about a system.
Think about a low-pass filter.
Think about a system
whose input is little vi
and whose output is little vo.
You all know how to characterize
that a gazillion ways.
You would know how to write a
differential equation for that.
Nod your head yes.
Yes, yes, yes?
You would know how to write
that as a differential equation.
You'd be able to write
a system function.
You'd be able to do a frequency
response, a Bode plot,
all those sorts of things.
That's fine.
What I want to do is think
about it instead as a filter.
So imagine the Bode plot.
The Bode plot is good, right?
So imagine the Bode
plot representation
for the RC low-pass filter.
So the RC low-pass
filter has a single pole.
The pole is at the
frequency 1 over RC.
Minus 1 over RC.
Bode plot looks like so.
Magnitude has an asymptote
at low frequencies
that is a constant.
At high frequencies, it's
sloping with minus 1.
Or, as we would say,
minus 20 dB per decade.
And it has some sort
of phase response.
Low frequencies, the phase is 0.
High frequencies, the
phase lags by pi over 2.
But now, let's think about
exciting it with a square wave.
Square wave is what we've
been thinking about.
Square wave has a harmonic
structure that falls with k.
So if we represent k equals
1, 3, 5, 7, 9 on a log scale,
falling with k is
a linear slope.
So this linear decrease
in amplitude height
is the reciprocal over here.
It's the idea of a log, right?
So we can represent the
signal, the square wave,
by this amplitude spectrum.
How big are the
components at all
of the different frequencies?
Well, there's only a
discrete number of them.
There's the k equals 1
one, the k equals 3 one,
the k equals 5 one, et cetera.
Each one represented
by a straight line.
And they all have phase of minus
pi over 2 because of the j.
Now, if you were to
choose the base frequency
for the square wave so that
2 pi over capital T omega 0
is small compared to
the cutoff frequency
for the low-pass
filter, what would
be the effect on these
amplitudes of this filter?
Well, the magnitude is 1.
So if you go to arbitrarily
low frequencies,
the magnitude is
arbitrarily close to 1.
If the phase is arbitrarily
close to pi over 2,
what would happen?
Excuse me, the phase would
be arbitrarily close to 0.
Sorry.
I'm supposed to be going
to very low frequencies.
If I go to very low
frequencies, the phase is 0.
If the amplitude is
arbitrary close to 1,
the phase is
arbitrarily close to 0.
And if the input is represented
by the red lines, what's
the output represented by?
Same red lines, right?
Each red line is
multiplied by 1 at angle 0.
So the output has the
same shape as the input.
If, however, I shift the
period to be shorter,
so that omega 0
is higher, then I
can have some of the
higher frequencies
fall into the region
of sloping magnitude.
I can have some of the
phases fall into the region
where the phase is
minus pi over 2.
The way to think about
it is the fundamental
is still going through the place
with unity gain phase of 0.
The basic shape is determined
by the fundamental.
The basic shape comes through.
But now the high frequencies
are being altered
and their phase relationship
is being altered.
And that's why the
shape is different.
If you go to still
higher frequencies,
more of the components
are filtered.
Each component gets sent
through the frequency response.
And its amplitude and phase
are modified appropriately.
And if you go to extremely
high frequencies,
then all of the
magnitudes are multiplied
by this sloping down line.
We turn k convergence-- we
turn the reciprocal in k
into a reciprocal on k squared.
Where have we seen that before?
That was the decomposition
for the triangle wave.
So the answer comes out
looking like a triangle wave.
The point being that
in addition to thinking
about how the system works in
terms of feeding frequencies
through it, now
we think about how
signals work by breaking
them up into frequency parts.
And the whole system
then is reduced to,
how does the system
modify that component?
So that gives rise to
the idea of thinking
about the system as a filter.
LTI systems do not
generate new frequencies.
All they do is modify
the amplitude and phase
of existing frequencies.
If you enumerate all of
the existing frequencies,
you can just go
through them one by one
and figure out
how they come out.
And that's an equivalent way of
thinking about an LTI system.
And that's the kind
of a focus that we'll
use in the remaining
part of the course.
OK,